Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and add free, you can support case file on your preferred platform. In late July 2015, 28-year-old civil engineer
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。本集最初是在 CaseFiles Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上发布的，作为我们付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些剧集并免除广告，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。2015 年 7 月下旬，28 岁的土木工程师
Mark Van Dongen was using an online dating site when he met a woman named Violet. Like Mark, Violet lived in the English. city of Bristol. The two chatted online for a week before deciding to meet up for a coffee. The first date went so well that they arranged to go to the cinema together a few days later. Affection quickly blossomed and by mid-August the pair were contemplating a serious relationship. There was just one problem. Mark already had a girlfriend. Five years earlier, he'd met a 40-year-old South African woman. named Berliner Wallace through an online dating site.
马克·范·东根（Mark Van Dongen）在使用一个在线约会网站时认识了一位名叫维奥莱特（Violet）的女士。和马克一样，维奥莱特也住在英国布里斯托尔市。两人在网上聊了一周后，决定见面喝杯咖啡。第一次约会非常成功，几天后他们就安排一起去看电影。感情迅速升温，到 8 月中旬，两人已经在考虑建立认真的恋爱关系。只有一个问题。马克已经有女朋友了。五年前，他通过一个在线约会网站认识了一位 40 岁的南非女性，名叫柏林娜·华莱士（Berlinah Wallace）。
Despite the 18-year age gap between the two and the fact they lived in different countries, they hit it off. Mark had been living in his home country of the Netherlands at the time, while Belina was living in the United Kingdom. Mark flew to the UK to take Berliner on a date, and the two became intimate. Mark returned to the Netherlands shortly after, but a few weeks later, Balina contacted him with some... news. She told him she was pregnant. Mark wanted to do the decent thing, so he relocated to the
尽管两人有 18 岁的年龄差，而且生活在不同的国家，但他们一见如故。当时马克住在他的祖国荷兰，而柏林娜住在英国。马克飞往英国与柏林娜约会，两人变得亲密起来。马克不久后回到荷兰，但几周后，柏林娜联系了他，带来了一些……消息。她告诉他她怀孕了。马克想做正确的事，于是他搬到了
UK. He moved in with Bellinor in Bristol, enrolled in university and found work as an engineer on a large construction project. But after a few months, Belina told Mark she'd miscarried the baby. Mark stayed in the relationship regardless, having developed strong feelings for Belina. The majority of his income was used to support Bellinna as well as her family back in South Africa. Over the years, the relationship struggled, and by the time Mark met Violet, he'd been planning to leave Bolina for a while. He had admitted the truth about his relationship status to Violet, and she wasn't exactly pleased by the news. The two decided to stop seeing each other until Mark sorted himself out. A few days later, Mark contacted Vali. A few days later, Mark contacted Vali.
英国。他搬去布里斯托尔与柏林娜同住，注册了大学，并在一个大型建筑项目中找到了一份工程师的工作。但几个月后，柏林娜告诉马克她流产了。马克对柏林娜产生了深厚的感情，因此无论如何都留在了这段关系中。他的大部分收入都用来支持柏林娜以及她在南非的家人。多年来，这段关系一直很艰难，到马克遇到维奥莱特时，他已经计划离开柏林娜一段时间了。他向维奥莱特承认了他恋爱关系的真相，而她对这个消息并不高兴。两人决定停止见面，直到马克处理好自己的事情。几天后，马克联系了维奥莱特。几天后，马克联系了维奥莱特。
Violet to say he'd ended things with Bellinna and was moving into a hotel. Mark and Violet agreed to rekindle their romance. However, Mark urged Violet not to send any more emails to his current address. His ex-girlfriend, Bolina Wallace, had hacked his account. At the end of August, Mark checked out of his hotel room and moved in with Violet. On the day he arrived, Violet was shot. shocked by what she saw. Mark had a fingernail gouge mark around his neck and nearly a dozen four-inch gouges on his back and chest. When Violet asked what happened, Mark said Berliner
维奥莱特说他已经和柏林娜分手了，正搬进一家酒店。马克和维奥莱特同意重燃爱火。然而，马克敦促维奥莱特不要再向他当前的地址发送任何电子邮件。他的前女友柏林娜·华莱士黑了他的账户。8 月底，马克退了酒店房间，搬去和维奥莱特同住。在他到达的那天，维奥莱特被她所看到的景象惊呆了。马克的脖子上有一道指甲抓痕，背部和胸部有近十几道四英寸长的抓痕。当维奥莱特问发生了什么事时，马克说柏林娜
had attacked him. Later that day, Violet began receiving anonymous phone calls. When she picked up, the caller on the other line remained silent. Over the next 72 hours, she received 13 more of calls. Meanwhile, Mark's mobile phone was ringing around the clock. It was Belina Wallace and she was not happy. Belina switched between screaming at Mark to crying and hyperventilating. On September 2, Belina made a call that finally pushed Mark over the edge. He contacted the police, telling the operator, I split up with my girlfriend and she keeps calling me. Now, she's blackmailing me. Mark Van Dongen told the emergency operator that when he ended things with Berliner Wallace two weeks earlier, she'd threatened to stab herself. She didn't
袭击了他。那天晚些时候，维奥莱特开始接到匿名电话。当她接听时，电话那头的人保持沉默。在接下来的 72 小时里，她又接到了 13 个这样的电话。与此同时，马克的手机响个不停。那是柏林娜·华莱士，她很不高兴。柏林娜在对马克尖叫和哭泣、过度换气之间切换。9 月 2 日，柏林娜打了一个电话，终于让马克忍无可忍。他联系了警察，告诉接线员：“我和女朋友分手了，她一直给我打电话。现在，她在勒索我。”马克·范·东根告诉紧急接线员，当他在两周前与柏林娜·华莱士分手时，她曾威胁要自残。她没有
go through with this threat, but instead grabbed a handful of pills and swallowed them in front of Mark. He phoned for an ambulance and Berliner was taken to hospital. After Mark moved out, she harassed him with phone calls and text messages. Finally, he received an email for from Bellina claiming that a close friend of hers had suffered a heart attack. She accused Mark of abandoning her in her time of need and demanded that he call her immediately. Mark reluctantly made the call. Belina was sobbing, saying she wouldn't stop crying until Mark came to see her in person. Mark refused, asking Bellinna to just leave him and his new girlfriend alone.
真的实施这个威胁，而是抓了一把药片，在马克面前吞了下去。他叫了救护车，柏林娜被送往医院。马克搬走后，她用电话和短信骚扰他。最后，他收到了一封来自柏林娜的电子邮件，声称她的一位密友心脏病发作了。她指责马克在她需要的时候抛弃了她，并要求他立即给她打电话。马克不情愿地打了电话。柏林娜在啜泣，说如果马克不亲自来看她，她就不会停止哭泣。马克拒绝了，要求柏林娜放过他和他的新女友。
He hung up, but Belina kept trying to call him back. back. Mark eventually picked up. Belina screamed that if he didn't do what she wanted, she'd call the police and tell them Mark had been downloading child abuse images. Exasperated, Mark called the police emergency line, telling the operator, something needs to be done about it. The next day, Mark went to the local police station and showed an officer that dozens of text messages and emails Belina Wallace had sent him. The officer believed the messages were pleading in nature rather than harassing,
他挂断了电话，但柏林娜一直试图回拨。马克最终接听了。柏林娜尖叫着说，如果他不按她说的做，她就会报警，告诉警察马克一直在下载虐待儿童的图片。马克忍无可忍，拨打了警察紧急电话，告诉接线员：“必须对此采取行动。”第二天，马克去了当地警察局，向一名警官展示了柏林娜·华莱士发给他的几十条短信和电子邮件。警官认为这些信息本质上是恳求，而不是骚扰，
but she agreed to speak with Berliner regardless. Later that day, the officer visited Berliner at her flat and explained that Mark Van Dongen had lodged a complaint against her. She urged Berliner to seek help from her GP if she was struggling with the breakup. The officer was also aware that Mark had agreed to continue paying Berliner's bill and the university tuition for her fashion degree. She recommended that Bolina contact an advice line if she was struggling financially. The officer explained that the silent phone calls to Violet's flat could be easily traced if necessary
但她还是同意与柏林娜谈谈。那天晚些时候，警官在柏林娜的公寓拜访了她，并解释说马克·范·东根对她提出了投诉。她敦促柏林娜如果难以接受分手，就向她的全科医生寻求帮助。警官还知道马克已同意继续支付柏林娜的账单和她时装学位的大学学费。她建议柏林娜如果经济困难，可以联系咨询热线。警官解释说，如果有必要，可以很容易地追踪到打给维奥莱特公寓的无声电话，
and instructed Belina to cease all contact with Mark and his new girlfriend. Less than three weeks later on September 21, Mark received another message from Belina. She said she was so devastated by their breakup that she planned to quit her university course and return to South Africa. She wanted Mark to give her money to pay for the plane ticket. Mark refused. The next day, Balena called Mark begging him to come see her. Given Belina's history of self-harm, Mark worried about what she might do to herself. He told Belina he would go to her flat that evening.
并指示柏林娜停止与马克及其新女友的所有联系。不到三周后的 9 月 21 日，马克收到了柏林娜的另一条信息。她说她对他们的分手感到非常崩溃，以至于她计划退学并返回南非。她想让马克给她钱支付机票。马克拒绝了。第二天，柏林娜打电话给马克，恳求他来看她。鉴于柏林娜有自残史，马克担心她可能会对自己做出什么事。他告诉柏林娜他那天晚上会去她的公寓。
But first, Mark went home to Violet. He reassured her that he was committed to their relationship, but felt that he needed to do this. Mark arrived at Berliner's flat on Lady Smith Road at about 6pm. As they prepared dinner, they chatted about their relationship. Mark reiterated that he had no intention of getting back together. An argument broke out, and at around 10pm, Ballina packed a few belongings and left the flat, saying she was going to check into a hotel.
但首先，马克回家找了维奥莱特。他向她保证他致力于他们的关系，但觉得他必须这样做。马克在大约晚上 6 点到达了位于史密斯夫人路（Lady Smith Road）的柏林娜的公寓。当他们准备晚餐时，他们聊起了他们的关系。马克重申他无意复合。争吵爆发了，大约晚上 10 点，柏林娜收拾了一些行李离开了公寓，说她要去住酒店。
Given the late hour, Mark decided to stay in the flat overnight. He undressed it down to his boxer shorts and slipped into bed. Soon, he was sound asleep. At 3 a.m., Balina's neighbour, Thomas, awoke to a screeching sound that he thought was foxes fighting. He grabbed a club from his golf bag, intending to break up the scuffle. But when he stepped outside, he realised it wasn't foxes. Someone was screaming the words, help me. Thomas ran to the end of Lady Smith Road and found Mark Van Dongen wearing nothing but boxer shorts. He was clearly in distress, but Thomas didn't
考虑到时间很晚，马克决定在公寓过夜。他脱得只剩下平角内裤，钻进了被窝。很快，他就熟睡了。凌晨 3 点，柏林娜的邻居托马斯（Thomas）被一种尖锐的声音惊醒，他以为是狐狸在打架。他从高尔夫球袋里抓起一根球杆，打算去阻止这场争斗。但当他走到外面时，他意识到那不是狐狸。有人在尖叫着“救救我”。托马斯跑到史密斯夫人路的尽头，发现马克·范·东根只穿着平角内裤。他显然处于痛苦之中，但托马斯并没有
understand what was happening. He thought perhaps Mark had taken LSD and was having a bad trip. It looked like he'd been to a rave. His face and upper body were covered in dark grey paint. A split second later, Thomas realised his mistake. He asked Mark what had happened. In a high-pitched distress, Mark cried out. Someone threw acid or something over me. Can't you see?
明白发生了什么。他以为马克可能吸了 LSD，正在经历糟糕的幻觉。他看起来像是刚从狂欢派对回来。他的脸和上半身覆盖着深灰色的油漆。一秒钟后，托马斯意识到了自己的错误。他问马克发生了什么事。马克用尖锐痛苦的声音哭喊道：“有人往我身上泼了酸还是什么东西。你看不见吗？”
Thomas immediately called emergency services. When the operator instructed Thomas, to ask Mark who did this to him, Mark responded, My ex. The operator told Thomas to take Mark to a shower and have him thoroughly wash his entire body. Other neighbours had emerged from their houses and one offered the use of his bathroom.
托马斯立即拨打了紧急服务电话。当接线员指示托马斯询问马克是谁对他做了这件事时，马克回答说：“我的前女友。”接线员告诉托马斯带马克去淋浴，让他彻底清洗全身。其他邻居也从屋里出来了，其中一人主动提出让他使用自己的浴室。
As the group ushered this still screaming Mark back down Lady Smith Road, his distress increased. He fearfully pointed at a flat and said, She lives there, she lives there. The group assured him he was being taken to a different flat. When Mark stepped into the harsh lighting of the bathroom, Thomas was shocked by what he saw. He reassured Mark that an ambulance and police were on the way. Mark replied,
当这群人护送着仍在尖叫的马克回到史密斯夫人路时，他的痛苦加剧了。他恐惧地指着一间公寓说：“她住在那儿，她住在那儿。”大家向他保证他正被带往另一间公寓。当马克走进浴室刺眼的灯光下时，托马斯被他看到的景象惊呆了。他向马克保证救护车和警察正在赶来。马克回答说：
They need to be here. She needs to pay. Paramedics quickly arrived to rush Mark to hospital, but all they could do was feed him constant supply of pain relieving gas along the way. Even so, Mark continued to scream in agony. He implored a police officer who was riding with them to check if his girlfriend Violet was okay. He then pointed to a tattoo on his lower stomach. It was the name Bellina.
“他们必须在这里。她必须付出代价。”医护人员很快赶到，将马克送往医院，但他们能做的只是在路上为他提供持续的止痛气体供应。即便如此，马克仍在痛苦中尖叫。他恳求随行的警官检查他的女友维奥莱特是否平安。然后他指了指下腹部的一个纹身。那是柏林娜的名字。
Mark told the officer, She needs to go to prison for this. Throughout the two-mile journey, Mark's distress, escalated. He kept shouting about his eyes, saying that he could hardly see. He begged those in the ambulance to tell him if he still had eyelids. On arrival, he was taken to the hospital's decontamination unit. Through the haze of his failing eyesight, Mark caught a brief glimpse of his own reflection. He screamed, Kill me now. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's
马克告诉警官：“她必须为此坐牢。”在两英里的路程中，马克的痛苦不断升级。他不停地大喊关于他的眼睛，说他几乎看不见了。他恳求救护车里的人告诉他是否还有眼睑。到达后，他被送往医院的去污室。透过视力衰退的模糊视线，马克短暂地瞥见了自己倒影。他尖叫道：“现在就杀了我。”Case file 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的
ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. The hospital's emergency doctor determined that Mark Van Dongen had been doused with highly corrosive, concentrated sulfuric acid. The acid had first covered Mark's entire face and then splashed down his body. Within seconds of the acid making. in contact, Mark's skin had been burned, turning to blackened dead tissue. By the time he arrived at the hospital, the skin on his face had melted away. His nose had completely disintegrated, and his left ear and both eyelids were gone. His eyes had turned grey and they were dissolving. Mark slipped into a coma. Officers converged on Berliner Wallace's flat. Berliner was sitting in her
广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Case File 继续提供优质内容。医院的急诊医生确定马克·范·东根被泼了高腐蚀性的浓硫酸。酸液首先覆盖了马克的整张脸，然后溅到了他的身上。在酸液接触后的几秒钟内，马克的皮肤就被烧焦，变成了发黑的坏死组织。当他到达医院时，他脸上的皮肤已经融化了。他的鼻子完全解体，左耳和双眼睑都不见了。他的眼睛变成了灰色，正在溶解。马克陷入了昏迷。警察聚集在柏林娜·华莱士的公寓。柏林娜正坐在她的
living room, appearing completely calm and collected. In front of her was a towel with a pair of acid wash jeans on top. Next to the jeans was a paintbrush and a glass mug with a few drops of clear liquid inside. One of the officers asked Berliner if she knew what substance had injured Mark. Berliner gestured to the items on the floor and replied, acid. I was using it to distress some fabric. The liquid in the mug had come from a white plastic bottle officers found on the kitchen table. It had no label but contained a clear, odourless liquid that proved to be sulfuric acid. Berliner claimed she'd originally bought the acid to clean out some of the flat, smelly drains. When officers went into the bedroom, they saw what looked like a black
客厅里，显得非常冷静和镇定。在她面前是一条毛巾，上面放着一条酸洗牛仔裤。牛仔裤旁边是一把画笔和一个玻璃杯，里面有几滴透明液体。其中一名警官问柏林娜是否知道是什么物质伤害了马克。柏林娜指着地上的物品回答说：“酸。我用它来做旧一些布料。”杯子里的液体来自警察在餐桌上发现的一个白色塑料瓶。它没有标签，但里面装有一种透明、无味的液体，经证明是硫酸。柏林娜声称她最初买这种酸是为了清理公寓里发臭的下水道。当警察走进卧室时，他们看到了看起来像黑色
tar splashed all over the bed. Upon closer inspection, they realized the substance was actually the white cotton bedding melted by acid. The blackened patches were concentrated on two pillows and a particular section of the duvet. Berliner Wallace was arrested and taken into custody. She claimed that just before 3am,
焦油溅满了床。仔细检查后，他们意识到这种物质实际上是被酸融化的白色棉质床上用品。发黑的斑块集中在两个枕头和被子的特定部分。柏林娜·华莱士被捕并被拘留。她声称在凌晨 3 点之前，
she and Mark had gotten into an argument. He became violent, and started to pull on her underwear. To defend herself, Bellina picked up a glass from the bedside table and threw its contents on Mark. She assumed it was filled with water as Mark always poured her a glass before bed. Prior to their fight, he'd told her to use it to take her medication. But when she saw Mark's skin turn black and smoke start to rise, Belina realized it wasn't water.
她和马克发生了争吵。他变得暴力，开始拉扯她的内衣。为了自卫，柏林娜拿起床头柜上的一个玻璃杯，把里面的东西泼在了马克身上。她以为里面装的是水，因为马克总是会在睡前给她倒一杯水。在他们争吵之前，他曾告诉她用它来服药。但当她看到马克的皮肤变黑并开始冒烟时，柏林娜意识到那不是水。
Mark began screaming in pain, so Berliner rushed him into the shower before going to grab some paper towels to wipe him down. Berliner told the detectives that Mark had put the acid into the glass himself, saying, He wanted me to burn my insides. Can you imagine? Can you imagine? Mark betrayed me. Detectives asked Berliner why she didn't call for an ambulance after Mark ran out of the flat street. screaming in pain. Belina said it hadn't even crossed her mind, explaining.
马克开始痛苦地尖叫，所以柏林娜冲进淋浴间，然后去拿纸巾帮他擦拭。柏林娜告诉侦探，马克是自己把酸放进杯子里的，说：“他想让我烧毁我的内脏。你能想象吗？你能想象吗？马克背叛了我。”侦探问柏林娜为什么在马克跑出公寓街头痛苦尖叫后没有叫救护车。柏林娜说她根本没想过，解释说：
You know, I was just confused about loads of things. I was confused. Detectives didn't buy Belina Wallace's story for a second. She said she'd purchased the acid to clean the flat strains, but these were tested and it was clear they hadn't been cleaned in quite some time. Berliner was charged with the offense of throwing a corrosive substance with the intent to burn, maimed, disfigure or disable Mark Van Dongen. With Mark in a coma and unable to assist the investigation, police turned to his family and friends to help. According to Mark's father, Case, his son had sought medical care four years earlier for burns to his arm.
“你知道，我只是对很多事情感到困惑。我很困惑。”侦探一秒钟都没有相信柏林娜·华莱士的故事。她说她买酸是为了清理公寓的下水道，但这些下水道经过测试，很明显已经很久没有清理过了。柏林娜被指控犯有泼洒腐蚀性物质意图烧伤、致残、毁容或使马克·范·东根丧失能力的罪行。由于马克处于昏迷状态，无法协助调查，警方转向他的家人和朋友寻求帮助。据马克的父亲凯斯（Case）说，他的儿子四年前曾因手臂烧伤寻求医疗护理。
Mark had told the doctor he'd dropped a hot cup of 10. over himself, but that was a lie. After arguing about something insignificant, Berliner crept up behind him while he was sitting on the sofa and threw boiling water over his arm. Case explained that Mark had always been more in love with Berliner than she was with him, but Berliner was jealous by nature. Mark had confided in his dad that Berliner sometimes hit herself in the face so she looked bruised and beaten. She She'd then threatened to report Mark for domestic violence if he ever left her. To prevent him from returning to the Netherlands or checking into a hotel,
马克告诉医生他把一杯热茶洒在了自己身上，但那是谎言。在争吵了一些无关紧要的事情后，柏林娜在他坐在沙发上时悄悄溜到他身后，把开水泼在了他的手臂上。凯斯解释说，马克一直比柏林娜爱他更爱柏林娜，但柏林娜天生嫉妒。马克曾向他父亲吐露，柏林娜有时会打自己的脸，这样她看起来就会有淤青和被殴打的样子。然后她会威胁说，如果马克离开她，就举报他家庭暴力。为了阻止他回到荷兰或住进酒店，
she sometimes stole his passport and hid it. A colleague of Marks recalled that Mark had once lifted his shirt to reveal fingernail gouge marks across his back and chest. Some were fresh, while others had already begun to heal and scar. Mark was a tall, strong man, often referred to a. was a gentle giant. When he stood next to Berliner, he towered over her petite frame. Yet, in the months leading up to the attack, Mark had confided in his father and friends that he was becoming more and more afraid of Berliner and what she might be capable of. Detectives obtained a
她有时会偷走他的护照并藏起来。马克的一位同事回忆说，马克曾经掀起衬衫，露出背部和胸部的指甲抓痕。有些是新的，而另一些已经开始愈合并留下疤痕。马克是一个高大强壮的人，常被称为“温柔的巨人”。当他站在柏林娜旁边时，他比她娇小的身材高出许多。然而，在袭击发生前的几个月里，马克曾向他的父亲和朋友吐露，他越来越害怕柏林娜以及她可能做出的事情。侦探获得了
warrant to access Berliner's psychological history. They discovered that in December 2013, she'd spoken with a university counsellor about her anger issues. She had admitted to being physically violent with people and to using threatening and intimidating behaviour, especially towards Mark. In a session with the university's psychiatric nurse the following year, Belina had described feeling an adrenaline rush whenever she felt wronged by someone.
访问柏林娜心理病史的搜查令。他们发现，2013 年 12 月，她曾与一名大学辅导员谈论过她的愤怒问题。她承认对人有身体暴力，并有威胁和恐吓行为，尤其是针对马克。在第二年与大学精神科护士的一次会谈中，柏林娜描述说，每当她感到被某人冤枉时，就会感到一种肾上腺素激增。
She said it made her want to destroy everything around her. After Mark ended their relationship, Berliner told this same nurse that she wasn't coping. She felt depressed, anxious, betrayed, and angry. Berliner had deleted her internet search history, but police were able to recover it. A forensic search of her phone and computer revealed that in the days leading up to the attack, Berliner had accessed 82 sites that showed the damage sulfuric acid burns could do to a human being. She viewed dozens of articles about victims who'd been horridged.
她说这让她想摧毁周围的一切。在马克结束他们的关系后，柏林娜告诉同一位护士她无法应对。她感到沮丧、焦虑、被背叛和愤怒。柏林娜删除了她的互联网搜索记录，但警方能够恢复它。对她的手机和电脑进行的法医搜索显示，在袭击发生前的几天里，柏林娜访问了 82 个展示硫酸烧伤对人体造成伤害的网站。她查看了数十篇关于受害者在被泼硫酸后受到可怕毁容的文章，
horribly disfigured after having sulfuric acid thrown in their faces, most of which were accompanied by graphic photographs. Berliner also googled phrases such as, what happens when you swallow sulfuric acid, and can I die from drinking sulfuric acid? On the same day that Mark Van Dongen contacted police asking that something be done about Berliner's blackmail threat, she visited the online store Amazon. For just over 17 pounds, Berliner bought a 1-liter bottle of 98% concentration sulfuric acid. The following day, an officer visited her to request that she stopped contacting Mark.
其中大多数都配有生动的照片。柏林娜还谷歌搜索了诸如“吞下硫酸会发生什么”和“喝硫酸会死吗”之类的短语。就在马克·范·东根联系警察要求对柏林娜的勒索威胁采取行动的同一天，她访问了在线商店亚马逊。柏林娜花了 17 英镑多一点，买了一瓶 1 升 98% 浓度的硫酸。第二天，一名警官拜访她，要求她停止联系马克。
After the officer left, Berliner phoned a mental health crisis hotline and told the operator she'd swallowed a handful of pills. An ambulance was dispatched and Belina was taken to hospital, but discharged the following day. A few days later, the bottle of sulfuric acid arrived. At some point, Belina removed the bottle's label which featured a very clear warning that the contents caused severe burns and dye damage. One of Belina's online searches had led her to a case from 15 years prior, in which Birmingham man Andrew Gardner had allegedly tricked his former girlfriend into drinking sulfuric acid as a last toast to mark the end of their relationship.
警官离开后，柏林娜给心理健康危机热线打了电话，告诉接线员她吞了一把药片。救护车被派往，柏林娜被送往医院，但第二天就出院了。几天后，那瓶硫酸到了。在某个时候，柏林娜撕掉了瓶子的标签，上面有一个非常明确的警告，即内容物会导致严重的烧伤和眼睛损伤。柏林娜的一次在线搜索将她引向了 15 年前的一个案件，在该案中，伯明翰男子安德鲁·加德纳（Andrew Gardner）据称诱骗他的前女友喝下硫酸，作为纪念他们关系结束的最后一杯祝酒。
The victim, 27-year-old doctor Karanina Lange, cried in agony for 23 minutes before Gardner called for an ambulance. By that time, the acid had destroyed Karanina's mouth, throat and internal organs. She died in hospital hours later, while Gardner drank beer at a local pub. He claimed that Karanina had drunk the acid herself, either mistaking it for a glass of water or intentionally. to take her own life. At Gardner's murder trial, the jury wasn't convinced by the prosecution's evidence and the accused walked free. Detectives couldn't help but note the similarities between this case and Berliner's claim
受害者，27 岁的医生卡拉尼娜·兰格（Karanina Lange），在加德纳叫救护车前痛苦地哭喊了 23 分钟。到那时，酸液已经摧毁了卡拉尼娜的嘴、喉咙和内脏器官。她在几小时后在医院死亡，而加德纳在当地一家酒吧喝啤酒。他声称卡拉尼娜是自己喝下的酸，要么是误把它当成了水，要么是故意自杀。在加德纳的谋杀审判中，陪审团没有被检方的证据说服，被告被无罪释放。侦探们不禁注意到这个案件与柏林娜声称
that Mark had tried to trick her into drinking acid. It was possible that she'd been inspired by Andrew Gardner's defense as a means to get away with her own crime. Mark's injuries were the most extensive and extreme that surgeons had. ever seen, so much so that photos of his injuries were withheld from the investigative team on account of being too disturbing. Not long after Mark lost consciousness, he'd been taken into surgery so that all of the dead tissue on his face and body could be cut away. Healthy sections of his skin from other parts of his body were removed and grafted over the exposed areas.
马克试图诱骗她喝酸之间的相似之处。她很可能受到了安德鲁·加德纳辩护的启发，以此作为逃脱自己罪行的手段。马克的伤势是外科医生见过的最广泛和最极端的，以至于他的伤势照片因太令人不安而被调查组扣留。马克失去知觉后不久，他就被送进了手术室，以便切除他脸部和身体上所有坏死的组织。他身体其他部位的健康皮肤被切除，并移植到暴露的区域。
By the time surgeons had completed the multiple procedures, nearly half of the of Mark's entire body surface had been impacted. His face was disfigured and he was blind in one eye, while doctors were only just able to save a tiny fraction of sight in the other. They had no choice but to amputate his left leg. Almost every internal function of Mark's body had been affected. His heart, liver and kidneys had all been permanently compromised, while his weakened gastrointestinal system caused him to bleed from his bowel.
当外科医生完成多次手术时，马克全身近一半的表面积受到了影响。他的脸被毁容了，一只眼睛失明，而医生勉强保住了另一只眼睛的一小部分视力。他们别无选择，只能截掉他的左腿。马克身体的几乎每一个内部功能都受到了影响。他的心脏、肝脏和肾脏都受到了永久性的损害，而他虚弱的胃肠系统导致他肠道出血。
The damage to Mark's throat was so severe that a tube was inserted down his throat to keep his airways open. Multiple lung infections prompted the use of a tracheostomy tube to remove the fluid from his lungs and prevent him choking to death. On a number of occasions, he went into septic shock, causing his blood pressure to drop to potentially fatal levels. Doctors battled constantly to keep Mark alive. Then, in January 2016, four months after he slipped into a coma, Mark Van Dongen woke up. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. As Mark regained consciousness, the full extent of his injuries became clear.
马克喉咙的损伤非常严重，以至于一根管子被插入他的喉咙以保持气道畅通。多次肺部感染促使使用气管切开管来清除肺部的液体，防止他窒息死亡。在多次情况下，他陷入了感染性休克，导致血压降至致命水平。医生们不断努力让马克活下去。然后，在 2016 年 1 月，在他陷入昏迷四个月后，马克·范·东根醒了过来。Case File 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供优质内容。当马克恢复知觉时，他伤势的严重程度变得清晰起来。
The acid had so severely damaged his motor nerves that he was completely paralysed, unable to move from the neck down. It had also eaten away at his vocal cords, rendering him unable to speak a word. Yet, Mark's ability to feel remained. In some parts of his body, the acid had decimated the muscle tissue. Because the acid was impossible for doctors to remove or neutralize completely. small traces of it continued to slowly erode Mark's bones. Meanwhile, the severe scarring all over Mark's skin caused unbearable itching. Doctors administered a constant flow of morphine, but it wasn't enough.
酸液严重损坏了他的运动神经，以至于他完全瘫痪，脖子以下无法动弹。它还腐蚀了他的声带，使他无法说出一个字。然而，马克的感知能力依然存在。在他身体的某些部位，酸液摧毁了肌肉组织。由于医生无法完全清除或中和酸液，它的微量痕迹继续缓慢地侵蚀马克的骨骼。与此同时，马克全身严重的疤痕引起了难以忍受的瘙痒。医生们持续注射吗啡，但这还不够。
Every second brought Mark excruciating pain. Mark remained confined to his hospital bed in the intensive care unit where a team of 29 specialists managed his constant care. He was fed intravenously and relied on a ventilator, dialysis machine and catheter. Frequent surgical procedures were necessary to ensure his survival. Mark's father, Case, lived and worked in Belgium. While Mark was comatose, Case traveled to England every Friday afternoon and stayed with Mark all weekend, returning to Belgium in time for work.
每一秒都给马克带来剧烈的痛苦。马克被限制在重症监护室的病床上，那里有一个由 29 名专家组成的团队负责他的持续护理。他通过静脉注射进食，并依赖呼吸机、透析机和导尿管。频繁的外科手术对于确保他的生存是必要的。马克的父亲凯斯住在比利时并在此工作。在马克昏迷期间，凯斯每周五下午前往英国，整个周末都陪着马克，周一及时赶回比利时上班。
on Monday. After Mark woke up, Case never left the hospital. He remained by his son's bedside for 23 hours a day. Case talked to Mark, hoping his voice would provide him with something to cling to. At times, Case noticed a flicker of responsiveness in Mark's face. He tried everything he could to help provide his son with some relief. He scratched Mark's itching skin and rearranged. his limbs to ease the nerve pain. Over time, Case helped Mark to relearn how to communicate. Case developed a painstaking system whereby he pointed to each letter of the alphabet written on a piece of paper.
马克醒来后，凯斯再也没有离开过医院。他每天在儿子床边守候 23 个小时。凯斯与马克交谈，希望他的声音能为他提供一些可以依靠的东西。有时，凯斯注意到马克脸上闪过一丝反应。他尽其所能帮助儿子缓解痛苦。他抓挠马克发痒的皮肤，并重新摆放他的四肢以缓解神经痛。随着时间的推移，凯斯帮助马克重新学习如何交流。凯斯开发了一套费力的系统，他指向写在纸上的字母表的每个字母。
When he reached the letter Mark needed, Mark would stick out his tongue, allowing him to spell out words. When asked who was responsible for his injuries, Mark spelled Belina. Eventually, doctors were able to fit a speaking valve to the end of the tube in Mark's throat. In July 2016, after five months of speech therapy, Mark regained some of his voice. Detectives took this opportunity to interview him in hospital. Mark recalled the night of the attack in vivid detail. At around 3am, he recalled waking up in the dark to the sound of laughing.
当他到达马克需要的字母时，马克会伸出舌头，让他拼出单词。当被问及谁应对他的伤势负责时，马克拼出了“柏林娜”。最终，医生能够将一个发声阀安装到马克喉咙里的管子末端。2016 年 7 月，经过五个月的言语治疗，马克恢复了一些声音。侦探们借此机会在医院采访了他。马克生动地回忆起袭击当晚的细节。大约凌晨 3 点，他记得在黑暗中醒来，听到卧室里有笑声。
in the bedroom. He heard Berliner's voice say, If I can't have you, no one can. Something then struck Mark in the face. It burned like hell and Mark let out a terrified scream. As he scrambled out of bed, the pain moved from his face down to his arms and chest. He ran from the bedroom and out into the street screaming. Along with the ongoing physical pain, Mark was played with the pain. Mark was played in the by recurring night terrors and flashbacks of the attack. He was diagnosed with depression and post-traumatic stress disorder and prescribed antidepressants. Mark's biggest desire was to regain some mobility.
他听到柏林娜的声音说：“如果我不能拥有你，谁也别想拥有。”然后有什么东西击中了马克的脸。它烧得像地狱一样，马克发出了惊恐的尖叫。当他从床上爬起来时，疼痛从他的脸部蔓延到他的手臂和胸部。他尖叫着跑出卧室，冲到街上。除了持续的身体疼痛，马克还受到袭击带来的反复夜惊和闪回的困扰。他被诊断出患有抑郁症和创伤后应激障碍，并开了抗抑郁药。马克最大的愿望是恢复一些活动能力。
He committed everything he had to intensive daily physiotherapy sessions. After months and months, Mark had a major breakthrough when he managed to lightly tickle his father's hand when placed near his own. Mark understood that he'd require extensive round-the-clock care for the rest of his life and would always be in constant agonising pain. Regardless, he clung to a glimmer of hope that he could have something closer to a normal life and eventually he raised the possibility of being discharged into a care home. Case suggested they both go back to Belgium, but Mark was keen to stay in England with Violet. She remained committed to their relationship and visited him in hospital every day.
他全身心地投入到每天密集的物理治疗中。几个月后，马克取得了重大突破，当他父亲的手放在他手边时，他成功地轻轻挠了挠父亲的手。马克明白，他余生都需要广泛的 24 小时护理，并且将永远处于持续的剧烈疼痛中。尽管如此，他仍紧紧抓住一丝希望，即他可以过上更接近正常的生活，最终他提出了出院去护理院的可能性。凯斯建议他们都回比利时，但马克渴望留在英国和维奥莱特在一起。她仍然致力于他们的关系，每天都在医院探望他。
On November 22, 2016, after 11 months in the ICU, Mark's wishes were granted when he was transferred to a care home. Mark insisted that his father returned to Belgium and resume his normal life. Later that same day, Case received a distraught phone call from Mark. Case knew immediately that he had to get his son out of the care home. He jumped into his car and drove the eight hours from Belgium back to England, arriving at the care home in the early hours of the morning. While waiting for a more reasonable time to approach, he decided to take a quick nap in the front seat.
2016 年 11 月 22 日，在重症监护室待了 11 个月后，马克被转移到一家护理院，他的愿望得到了满足。马克坚持让他的父亲回比利时恢复正常生活。当天晚些时候，凯斯接到了马克心烦意乱的电话。凯斯立刻知道他必须把儿子从护理院接出来。他跳上车，开了八个小时从比利时回到英国，在凌晨到达了护理院。在等待更合理的时间进行接触时，他决定在前座小睡一会儿。
But Case soon heard screaming and he knew right away that those screams were coming from his son. Case ran up to the home and banged frantically on the door. Eventually, a staff member opened it. When Case entered Mark's room, he was shocked by what he found. Mark was lying on the bed, covered in his own feces. The staff had refused to go anywhere near him, too terrified of his appearance. Case hired a private ambulance and Mark was transferred to a hospital in Belgium that St. day, where he was placed in a palliative care unit. While a team of eight specialists assessed Mark's
但凯斯很快听到了尖叫声，他立刻知道那些尖叫声来自他的儿子。凯斯跑到护理院，疯狂地敲门。最终，一名工作人员打开了门。当凯斯进入马克的房间时，他被所见景象惊呆了。马克躺在床上，身上沾满了自己的粪便。工作人员拒绝靠近他，因为被他的外表吓坏了。凯斯雇了一辆私人救护车，马克当天被转移到比利时的一家医院，在那里他被安置在姑息治疗病房。当一个由八名专家组成的团队评估马克的
condition, case remained by his side until the nurses became accustomed to his appearance. By the end of November, Mark was informed of his prognosis. No amount of physical therapy would ever restore movement to his body. The paralysis was permanent. For Mark, this was the straw that broke the camel's back. He had nothing left and wished to end his life. On December 1, Mark submitted an application for voluntary euthanasia. Case could do nothing but support his son's wishes. Euthanasia was lawful under Belgian law provided strict control requirements were followed. Special-qualified doctors and psychologists assessed Mark's application.
情况时，凯斯一直守在他身边，直到护士们习惯了他的外表。11 月底，马克被告知了他的预后。任何物理治疗都无法恢复他身体的活动能力。瘫痪是永久性的。对马克来说，这是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草。他一无所有，希望结束自己的生命。12 月 1 日，马克提交了自愿安乐死申请。凯斯除了支持儿子的愿望外别无他法。只要遵循严格的控制要求，安乐死在比利时法律下是合法的。特别合格的医生和心理学家评估了马克的申请。
They considered Mark to be mentally competent. and found that his application had been made freely and voluntarily. They concluded that Mark was and would remain in a medically futile state of unbearable physical and psychological suffering. His application was approved. The law required Mark to wait for a period of 30 days before the euthanasia could be performed. Case tried to convince Mark to come home with him during that time, but Mark refused, saying it would just another ceiling to look at.
他们认为马克在精神上是有能力的，并发现他的申请是自由和自愿提出的。他们得出结论，马克处于并将继续处于一种医学上无效的、无法忍受的身体和心理痛苦状态。他的申请获得了批准。法律要求马克等待 30 天，然后才能执行安乐死。凯斯试图说服马克在那段时间和他一起回家，但马克拒绝了，说那只会是“另一片可以盯着看的天花板”。
One week before the procedure was due to be carried out, Mark developed another lung infection. Another tracheostomy tube was needed to remove the fluid from his lungs. Doctors told Mark that without it, there was a high chance he would choke and die. However, doctors also explained that if they did go ahead with the procedure, there was a 96% chance that would further damage his vocal cords and he could lose his voice completely. Mark's only wish was to be able to talk to his dad until the very last second. He declined the treatment. By January 2, 2017, 15 and a half months had passed since the acid attack.
在程序执行前一周，马克又患上了肺部感染。需要另一根气管切开管来清除肺部的液体。医生告诉马克，如果没有它，他很有可能会窒息而死。然而，医生也解释说，如果他们继续进行该程序，有 96% 的可能性会进一步损害他的声带，他可能会完全失去声音。马克唯一的愿望是能够和他的父亲交谈到最后一秒。他拒绝了治疗。到 2017 年 1 月 2 日，距离酸液袭击已经过去了 15 个半月。
At 7.15 p.m. that day, Mark shared a final drink with his father, and said goodbye. Doctors administered the lethal injection into Mark's heart. After Mark's death, Case told Channel 4 news. That boy went through hell and back. So much pain, so much itching, enough to drive anyone insane, completely paralyzed. Getting a bullet would be better in comparison. This has been nothing short of torture.
那天晚上 7 点 15 分，马克与父亲喝了最后一杯酒，并告别了。医生将致命注射剂注入马克的体内。马克去世后，凯斯告诉第四频道新闻：“那个孩子经历了地狱般的折磨。太多的痛苦，太多的瘙痒，足以让任何人发疯，完全瘫痪。相比之下，中一颗子弹会更好。这简直就是折磨。”
It defies belief. When news of Mark's death reached England, Berliner Wallace was immediately charged with another crime, murder. Her trial commenced nine months later in November 2017. Berliner's defense team contested the murder charge, claiming there was no case to answer, because Mark Van Dongen had chosen to end his own life. The judge decided that the euthanasia
这令人难以置信。当马克去世的消息传到英国时，柏林娜·华莱士立即被指控犯有另一项罪行：谋杀。她的审判在九个月后的 2017 年 11 月开始。柏林娜的辩护团队对谋杀指控提出异议，声称没有理由进行答辩，因为马克·范·东根选择了结束自己的生命。法官裁定，安乐死
was a voluntary act that broke the link between the acid attack committed by Bellinna and Mark's death. For a murder charge to apply, an unbroken link was legally required. The judge therefore ordered that the charge of murder be withdrawn. The prosecution immediately appealed and nine days later, the appeal court handed down its ruling. Even though Mark's decision to die was voluntary for the purpose of the Belgian law on euthanasia, it did not automatically mean his death was voluntary in the context of how and why he came to that decision. The appeal court ruled that the link had not been severed from a legal standpoint. Whether it had been factually severed was a question to be put to a jury. In May 2018, Berliner Wallace stood trial on both charges, throwing the acid with intent
是一种自愿行为，打破了柏林娜实施的酸液袭击与马克死亡之间的联系。要适用谋杀指控，法律上要求存在不间断的联系。因此，法官下令撤销谋杀指控。检方立即提出上诉，九天后，上诉法院做出了裁决。尽管马克选择死亡在比利时安乐死法律的范围内是自愿的，但这并不自动意味着他的死亡在关于他如何以及为何做出该决定的背景下是自愿的。上诉法院裁定，从法律角度来看，联系并没有被切断。它是否在事实上被切断是一个需要提交给陪审团的问题。2018 年 5 月，柏林娜·华莱士因两项指控受审：蓄意泼洒酸液
as well as murder. She testified in her own defence, sticking to the story that Mark himself had filled the glass with acid and tried to trick her into drinking it before launching an assault. Berliner told the jury that she threw what she thought was water over Mark just to make him stop. Through tears, she insisted that she hadn't meant to hurt him. Berliner claimed she'd never even read the articles about other acid attacks that were found in her online search history.
以及谋杀。她在自己的辩护中作证，坚持马克自己把酸液装进杯子并试图诱骗她喝下，然后发动袭击的故事。柏林娜告诉陪审团，她泼出她以为是水的东西在马克身上只是为了让他停下来。她含泪坚持说她无意伤害他。柏林娜声称她甚至从未阅读过在她在线搜索历史中发现的关于其他酸液袭击的文章。
She said she only looked at the pictures of the victims out of curiosity, labeling the timing as, just a coincidence, just bad luck. The jury heard a recording of Mark's 2016 hospital interview with detectives, in which Mark detailed Ballina Wallace's controlling and violent behavior during their five-year relationship. He described waking up on the night of the attack to Belina laughing, and repeated what she'd said just before throwing the acid on his face.
她说她只是出于好奇才看受害者的照片，将时间巧合称为“只是巧合，只是运气不好”。陪审团听取了马克 2016 年在医院接受侦探采访的录音，其中马克详细描述了柏林娜·华莱士在他们五年关系中的控制和暴力行为。他描述了在袭击当晚醒来时听到柏林娜的笑声，并重复了她在把酸液泼到他脸上之前所说的话。
If I can't have you, no one can. The judge instructed the jury to consider a series of questions to reach their verdicts. On the first count, the jury had to decide whether Bellinna's act of throwing acid over Mark was deliberate. If so, was it done with the intention of causing Mark's serious bodily harm? The jury's decision here was unanimous. Belina Wallace was guilty. However, for Belina to be guilty of the second count, murder, the jury had two more questions to consider. The first was whether the acid attack caused Mark's death.
“如果我不能拥有你，谁也别想拥有。”法官指示陪审团考虑一系列问题以达成裁决。在第一项指控上，陪审团必须决定柏林娜向马克泼酸的行为是否是蓄意的。如果是，它是为了造成马克严重身体伤害而做的吗？陪审团在此项决定上达成了一致。柏林娜·华莱士有罪。然而，要使柏林娜犯有第二项指控——谋杀罪，陪审团还有两个问题需要考虑。第一个是酸液袭击是否导致了马克的死亡。
While the attack didn't need to be the only cause, the jury had to be satisfied that it was a significant cause. If their answer was no or if they were unsure, they were required to acquit Belina. But if they had no doubt that Berliner's attack was a significant cause of Mark's death, there was one final question to consider. Could Belina have predicted that Mark might choose to end his own life as a result of his injuries? If the answer was yes, then Berliner would be guilty. After 15 and a half hours of deliberation, the jury reached their verdict. They found Berliner Wallace not guilty of murder.
虽然袭击不一定是唯一的原因，但陪审团必须确信它是造成死亡的重要原因。如果他们的回答是否定的，或者他们不确定，他们就必须判贝琳娜无罪。但如果他们毫无疑问地认为贝琳娜的袭击是导致马克死亡的重要原因，那么还有一个最终问题需要考虑。贝琳娜是否能预见到马克可能会因为伤势而选择结束自己的生命？如果答案是肯定的，那么贝琳娜就有罪。经过15个半小时的审议，陪审团做出了裁决。他们裁定贝琳娜·华莱士谋杀罪名不成立。
Addressing Berliner directly, the judge called her a manipulative and controlling woman who lied without compunction or conscience in an attempt to avoid culpability. She stated, Your intention was to burn, disfigure and disable Mark Van Dongen so that he would not be attractive to any other woman. You ignored Mark's cries of pain and chose not. to telephone the emergency services when you would have known that Mark urgently required medical help. You caused Mark catastrophic and life-changing injuries and 15 months of intense physical and psychological suffering. It was premeditated and sadistic. It was an act of pure evil. For the
法官直接对贝琳娜说，她是一个操纵人心、控制欲强的女人，为了逃避罪责，她毫无愧疚或良心地撒谎。她说：你的意图是烧伤、毁容并致残马克·范·东根，这样他就不会再吸引其他女性。你无视马克的痛苦呼喊，选择不拨打急救电话，尽管你当时肯定知道马克急需医疗救助。你给马克造成了灾难性的、改变人生的伤害，以及长达15个月的剧烈身心痛苦。这是蓄谋已久的、残忍的。这是一种纯粹的邪恶行为。对于
acid attack on Mark Van Dongen, Bolina Wallace was sentenced to life imprisonment, with a minimum term of 12 years, starting from the date of her arrest. Berliner will be eligible for parole in 2007, although the judge stressed that Berliner would only ever be released if she no longer posed a danger to the public. The attack on Mark in 2015 was just one of hundreds of acid attacks across the United Kingdom that year. In response to the alarming rise of acid being used as a weapon, the government introduced new restrictions to make it more difficult to obtain. From July 2018, a special license was required to purchase sulfuric acid in any
对马克·范·东根的泼酸袭击，贝琳娜·华莱士被判处终身监禁，最低刑期为12年，从她被捕之日起算。贝琳娜将于2007年获得假释资格，尽管法官强调，只有在贝琳娜不再对公众构成危险的情况下，她才会被释放。2015年对马克的袭击只是当年英国数百起泼酸袭击事件中的一起。为了应对酸液被用作武器的惊人增长，政府出台了新的限制措施，使其更难获得。从2018年7月起，购买任何
concentration above 15%. This regulation would have prevented Bolina Wallace from attacking Mark Van Dongen with such a devastating substance. The UK's then Minister for Crime, Safeguarding and Vulnerability told the press. This tragic case illustrates. the devastating consequences of acid attacks, and we are determined to end these appalling acts of violence. Berliner's life sentence brought little relief to Mark's father, who had described his son
浓度超过15%的硫酸需要特殊许可证。这项规定本可以阻止贝琳娜·华莱士用这种毁灭性的物质袭击马克·范·东根。英国时任犯罪、保障和脆弱性大臣对媒体表示：这起悲剧案件说明了泼酸袭击的毁灭性后果，我们决心结束这些骇人听闻的暴力行为。贝琳娜的终身监禁并没有给马克的父亲带来多少安慰，他曾形容他的儿子
as a gentleman and everyone's friend. Case ultimately felt that Mark was too good for this world. Addressing reporters after the trial, Case was shaking, as he said. Mark was so brave when he was so brave when he was. confronted with the hellish pain and disabilities inflicted upon him, but eventually it all became too much for him to bear. The court process has been a difficult and emotional experience. I am very disappointed in the outcome of this trial.
是一位绅士，也是每个人的朋友。凯斯最终觉得马克太好了，不属于这个世界。审判结束后，凯斯在面对记者时颤抖着说：马克在面对施加给他的地狱般的痛苦和残疾时是如此勇敢，但最终这一切让他无法承受。法庭审理过程是一次艰难且充满情感的经历。我对这次审判的结果感到非常失望。
There are only losers in this case. I hope that Mark can now rest in peace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在这个案件中只有输家。我希望马克现在能安息。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。